now someone share this with me
what the hell is this
this video
i
did
as they would say nickel in german it
means a furry devil
when they when they depicted him they
depicted him as a man with red fur
he had red fur coat it's been going
around as is that time of the year and i
was thinking about this
and i was thinking about habib
and i was thinking about khabib hamza as
they're in this area as public figures
who like it or not have a huge
responsibility
and what we love about khabib is
[Music]
[Applause]
i want to say something
i want i want to stay humble
alhamdulillah
everything god gave me how he always
attributes his success and praise to the
one of above god almighty the creator of
allah and he keeps it humble
undisputed
ufc
lightweight champion of the world
khabib
the eagle
nurmagomedov
he talks about the one god first of all
i wanna say alhamdulillah
without god we cannot do nothing
everything is nothing you know number
one
believe on your own god and he shares
his basic knowledge no one is expecting
him or you to be a scholar to convey the
simple basics of the deen as the prophet
saw some had said prophet muhammad last
found the messiah sent to mankind convey
for me even if it be one ayah
[Applause]
we pray the best for our brother hamzat
as we try to reach out to him and his
management didn't hear back
so i want to talk about this especially
during these times by being very very
careful to what we call the
desensitization
or being desensitized to the point where
everything to you becomes oh what's the
big deal we're just having fun
what the hell is this
let me give you an extreme example or
not so extreme because it's becoming
more normal and normal as the day goes
by
if we were to ask our brother hamzat or
somebody else you know because this
movement is growing and growing and we
asked him in the essence of hey having
fun hey would you wear this rainbow
colored outfit again for fun for good
times for laughs
let's switch it would habib do it i
don't think so would hamza do it
if he knows the roots
if he knows the roots and what it stands
for and what it promotes
probably emphatically he would not
that's just one example just like he's
against drugs and other things that his
deen his way of life islam prohibits
that's why he refused to go on the mike
tyson podcast
[Music]
do you think habib would compromise in
this area think about it this area to
promote or imitate a pagan festival let
me know in the comments below but
honestly i don't think hamzad would
either if he had this knowledge
beforehand and if he had someone who had
his best interest in mind not just for
the dunya but also for the akhirah for
the hereafter so inshallah after he
watches this and our brothers and
sisters in russia and dagestan
and some we have some very passionate
brothers all over the area of the world
especially in chechnya you know brothers
and sisters who love the dean who are
passionate about the deen about sharing
the deen you know if once they go ahead
and get a hold of this and they share it
with him because these are people who
are upon the quran and the sunnah and
they would not also approve of this
celebrating or being a part of imitating
any type of pagan festivals because
these are people also who are on the
pure monotheism the tawheed and they
love their deen so inshallah god well
after hamzad and others have been thrown
into this public arena and they have the
public eye and they have a huge
responsibility
they don't want to end up trying to
ingratiate themselves with fans trying
to win fans over at the expense of doing
things that are displeasing to god
almighty allah and inshallah after he
grows we grow all of us because we're
all works in progress become grows to
become better as we all should that's
including myself
because i'm not better than any one of
you guys i'm just trying to do my small
part so just a few things i want to
share and remind the people with that's
number one that these
things they go against these festivals
pagan festivals they go against the
essence of tohit that pure monotheism
that every messenger that god almighty
allah sent
brought and taught it goes against this
just look at the quran for example
chapter 112 of the quran
so it's a major crime
in front of allah god almighty the
creator is a major crime to imitate to
congratulate mary shirk to participate
and remember that the prophet saw some
remember this you can repeat it in
dagestani and russian and chechnyan
whatever the case
in your language the prophet saw some
had said look look he said to emma this
is a very important hadith whoever
imitates a people is one of them this is
an abu dhabu so there's also the hadith
of the lizard
said that in the future muslims will
follow the state of the jewish and
christians even if they enter the lizard
war the muslims will follow it so
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam had
already warned us that we would not
follow the jewish or christians customs
so celebrate christmas is not good for
muslims the whole of richard is
toothmore but if they went into a lizard
hole you're going to go follow them into
a lizard hole you don't want to end up
being a sycophant you don't want to just
again trying to ingratiate trying to
please the people and then at the
expense of this pleasing allah you know
hadith for the prophet saw some said
look if whoever works to please the
people at the expense of displeasing
allah allah will end up having this
people displeased with them and allah
will be
displeased with them at the end but
whoever works to please allah
at the expense of displeasing the people
at the end of the day allah will be
pleased with him and he'll make the
people
at the end be pleased with them just
take khabib for example who didn't bend
on these principles
who attributes all success to god
almighty allah allah honored him
now in this time of the year you have a
perfect example or other times like for
instance
or anybody else if if your peers or
someone asks you about ramadan is it
ramadan famous yeah
yeah i don't know we stopped the train
right enough
why are you pulling my abs off
when come ramadan this is everything for
me i don't think about fight because i
believe in one god this is my religion
religion for me number one sport is not
for me number one did you did you fast
for 30 days
was it hard
was a tough fashion for 30 days
yeah yeah take that time like during
ramadan or this time of the year to go
ahead and remind them that we believe in
jesus we love jesus you can't be a
muslim unless you believe in jesus the
messiah born of a virgin miraculously
did many miracles by the permission of
god almighty allah we love him as a
mighty messenger who never ever claimed
to be a god a literal son of god was
never part of a trinity but he prayed to
god he ate food he slept he worshipped
the one god and he called people to
worship god almighty allah never himself
and his companions they never took him
as divine
as a partner next to god and never did
he or his companions or the early church
or the early christians celebrate this
type of pagan these type of pagan
festivals in actuality the christian
church banned this is the church of
england they prohibited
this festival all the way up until 1647.
the because this they knew this had
historical roots connected to paganism
specifically this saturnalia
you know this celebrating the pagan gods
gods and then when you get into saint
nicholas when you go deeper and you look
into the history of the man and the
what's commonly known today as
they have santa claus parades and saint
nicholas is outside and he's in the
streets and everybody's talking about
saint nicholas and the poor children are
taught that saint nicholas is going to
come down your chimney most people don't
have chimneys in miami anyway
but a 350 pound man is going to come
down your chimney and the father the
poor father who sweat and toiled all
year to get you the presents gets no
credit for the present given to the
child
saint nicholas comes down the chimney
gives you this present flies off into
the night
and many of us were raised
thinking believing in this some of us
would sneak into the night and look and
see our father putting the present under
the tree we knew what he was doing
anyway
but you went along with it and the
people say well you know it's christmas
don't you like to have fun
you want to stop the children from
having fun
what kind of people are you but what is
the what are you teaching the children
you are using the name of jesus using
the name of isa alaihissalam and you are
using a figure who historically is the
devil
the devil himself
ended up hijacking the name of jesus to
push this pagan rooted festival which
again many christians do not celebrate
friends who do not celebrate christmas
because they say december 25th is really
a pagan holiday while i agree that jesus
may not have been born on december 25th
he certainly was born as described in
the bible how do i respond to them
well in a sense tell them they're right
that has nothing to do with the real
jesus and this figure saint nicholas
when you who's the modern-day santa
claus who is historically rooted as the
devil the devil himself will yeah
[Music]
they are using his figure and he has now
taken over the christmas season
christmas now to most people means
materialism you have to buy presents for
your cousins and your friends and you
gotta buy about 34 uh presents and you
find that most american people are in
debt for six months after christmas
now where is jesus you get drunk
you fight
you lose all your money the stores raise
their prices
let's also look at what some of our
brothers in humanity are saying the
christians
i quit christmas this year it has been
the best thing that i've ever done and
my soul feels so much better another
christian comments growing up in a
strict christian family i never
celebrated christmas my whole life
we were always made fun of by other
christian denominations but we never
stopped that is clearly sad in the bible
not to idol worship god these festivals
are created by the namesake christians
who just want to design and celebration
as
per their own
wishes amy lynn says i'm a christian and
i stop celebrating christmas around 10
years ago the whole santa thing
and the lies turned me off never
realized there are others like me i
actually don't celebrate any holidays
here's john paul thomas
he's another christian who talks about i
quit celebrating christmas for the first
time this year i'm 33 years old i try to
explain to my family and friends that
christmas is not christian but they all
look at me like i'm nuts however it's
good to know that there are still some
true christians out there who take
biblical scriptures seriously so this
christian here is talking about
you know the ones who really look into
the bible who take the scripture of
theirs seriously they'll see this whole
thing with the trees and all these other
festivals that are
these practices are incorporated with
today's christmas these all have roots
back in paganism and that's why it was
outlawed by the church
by the christian authority all the way
up
until
1647. so again you have a lot of
christians who went into and did some
basic research and they came to the same
conclusion i wanted to find out the
truth about christmas
so i started doing my own research and i
was shocked at what i found out
after doing just a little bit of
research like looking in an encyclopedia
i quickly found out that nearly
everything about christmas comes from
pagan traditions
the tree the holly mistletoe tinsel
lights gifts caroling and santa claus
and many other popular christmas
traditions all find their roots in
paganism
i was so disgusted at the pagan origins
of some of our traditions that i began
to weep and repent from my involvement
in those things
i felt so deceived and what made it
worse is that the lies came from people
i trusted like my family friends and
pastor so the question is why would any
muslim want to because a muslim is one
who submits his will to the creator of
heavens and earth and he's not tolheed
he's on that pure monotheism why would
he want to dress up like this why would
a muslim want to dress up and imitate
when the prophet saw said the one who
imitates the people a will be one of
them you'll be with those who you love
so it's very important
it goes back to some basics it goes back
to knowledge we have to be well grounded
in the nadine so if you're someone who's
a martial artist a fighter you're well
grounded in takedowns a double leg
single leg you have to know certain
principles of the martial art you have
to know how to throw a jab across if
you're going to be in mixed martial arts
if you don't know these things then what
i mean and you get knocked out whose
fault was it you didn't prepare you
didn't get knowledge what about your
dean tomorrow it's not enough to remain
ignorant and then go out in a public
space and then what youngsters old
stairs people see you and unfortunately
people are looking to people such as
yourself and others who are up there
because they're seeing them pray they're
seeing them raise their hands into ah
and next thing you know they end up
doing certain things and the credulous
naive folk the young ones they end up
what because we're creatures of
imitation they want to follow somebody
so now why not have them follow you in
the good rather than slipping up making
these blunders and inshallah you never
do that again
so my brothers and sisters it's
extremely important that we set good
examples good trends we want to be
grounded in our deen so when i ask you
[Music]
alhamdulillah i want to say something
i want i want to stay humble
alhamdulillah
everything god gave me
[Music]
undisputed
ufc
lightweight
champion of the world
khabib
the eagle
number
first of all i wanna say alhamdulillah
without god we cannot do nothing
everything is nothing you know number
one
believe on your one god versus
hamza
will kill everybody i'll stay here it's
my home allah
everybody i come here for
kill
everybody
i'm the jeff i'm the king
[Applause]
hamza has some great
qualities inshallah he can learn a lot
from habib
who's also been through this arena he's
been on the spotlight on the big
platform and we're not talking about and
endorsing the whole fight game and
whatnot these are people who already
been committed here you know you're
getting a hard time talking them out of
it and getting out of this but at the
end of the day now they've been put in a
position they have a big influence a big
reach
and a big responsibility and it's not
enough like when the billionaire was
asked by the sheikh he said what are you
doing for the dean for islam what are
you doing he says he says what are you
doing for allah he says well i go to
hajj every year you know i go to um
he said that's for you the prayer is for
you the hajj is for you what are you
doing for the deen that's the ultimate
question i mean if you look at the quran
and the sunnah look the prophet saw said
if you love me if you love my sunnah you
love me and those who love me will be
with me in jannah what's his sunnah
what's his way that's the thing what's
his way if you open up chapter 12 of the
quran god almighty allah is saying look
that the prophet saw i'm saying he's
saying
say this is my way i invite to allah
look at this i invite god to allah to
the creator on clear evidence look
that's his way
in chapter 16 of the quran god almighty
allah is saying look invite all to the
way of allah
with wisdom and beautiful preaching it's
our way
the way of the prophet saws the way of
jesus moses abraham they had the best
jobs they were conveying the message
they were conveying the message they
were conveying the purpose of life to
the people so when you have this big
platform it's not enough to be like look
i go to hajj i go to i pray look what
are you doing now for allah
what are you doing for this dean you've
been given this
star studded platform you've been giving
this opportunity with all the lights on
you just by the few words that khabib
was i'm a witness to that i've
interviewed someone from the mexican
cartel he's watching habib and he's
saying one god and he's saying he's
being humble he's not you know blasting
his chest pointing up above
look
these things have an impact on people
the same way you we get out there and
what we say how we act if we're acting
in the proper way with good ah good
manners good character that again that's
that's going to have an impact but at
the same time who's your sponsor
you know it's interesting a lot of the
people will get out there they'll throw
the nike on and the other sponsorships
out there and they don't go ahead and
check in oh nike and then you do some
research and you see all the uber forced
labor that's going on in there the slave
labor but you wear the nike for the
money for the money that's your sponsor
right so you for a few t-shirts right
you sell yours you go ahead and promote
it what about the dean
allah is the ultimate sponsor he's the
one who gave your health your eyes your
ears everything you wouldn't be able to
fight in the kit you wouldn't be able to
be where you're at without
the blessings of allah
so when allah talks about through the
prophet saw said look when the one who
mentions allah in a gathering allah
mentions him in a better gathering so
when you're out there let your behavior
be the best
be grounded in the deen take some time
instead of the music blocks box in the
car when you're working out put the
headphones on if everybody else is
listening to it you don't have to put a
good lecture on put there's so many
videos out there that you can be
watching that are educational get
yourself well grounded well
now the second goes by that you have the
intention to get closer to know your
deen more because through knowing your
dna you're going to know your creator
and the more you know him the more
you're going to love him and then you're
going to want to do what he wants you to
do and then you're going to be so
excited about your deen you're not going
to no one's going to have to tell you
you have to share this incumbent on you
to share you're going to want to share
it because you share those things that
you love and you want the best for
humanity that's why you're going to
share the deen with humanity but if you
don't if you're not grounded in your
deen just going through the rituals
emotions
it's like hey there's no fuel in the car
it's just rituals these are just
movements and again brother this is with
love
with passion for the deen with love for
our brothers and sisters for habib
hamzat all these brothers you know no
better than them and i just want the
best for them i want the best for all of
mankind so inshallah this helps
you know from the layman to them that
inshallah we can make better decisions
we can take some advice first for myself
that we're always looking to improve
ourselves to grow to become better
examples so we can go ahead and live
this deen better and we can communicate
the message better and inshallah we can
leave a legacy a true legacy behind
because at the end of the day all those
ufc belts and titles and championships
none of that stuff at the end is it's
worthless it's garbage
you know but if we're able to inspire
people if we're able to make some
positive changes in this world
we're able to enhance our lives in other
people's lives and we're able to deliver
this message and people are able to
benefit from them and they're able to
extract all the solutions that it has
for mankind in it
then inshallah
we had
done our small part and another surprise
you guys can go ahead and get the free
copy of the quran call us
1-800-662-islam
1-800-662-4752 if you want to know what
inspires khabib
what inspires
other muslims to be people who are on
the pure monotheism people who are
trying to be good neighbors
who are trying to be good human beings
who are trying to live a morally upright
life
get with us so we can get you a copy of
it if you want to know the purpose of
life you want to call us
1-800-662-4752 call us
and we'll see you next time again like
the video support us on our patreon page
continue to tune in every week to the
dean show peace be with you assalamu
alaikum